HM allez du théâtre pour continuer le
collège sainte- Thérèse du Ménil Saint-
mène une expérimentation culturelle
auprès d'élèves dit décrocheur un
entretien qui a été réalisé sur le
plateau du 78 avec Wilfred Richi et
Aurélia
[Musique]
debissi dans cette édition du 78 weekend
nous avons décidé de mettre l'action sur
une initiative du du Menil saint-ni un
collège du Menil saint-ni qui a décidé
de se servir du théâtre pour aider les
élèves en difficulté bonsoiré tout
bonsoir WIF et donc à cette occasion
nous recevons Christine mon bonsoir et
Étienne Mirabel donc Christine Meron
vous êtes professeur de français donc au
collège sainte- Thérèse au
ménilsint-denis vous accompagnez en
l'occurrence une classe de 4e donc la
classe 4e à projet cette classe donc est
un peu spécifique dites-nous quelle est
de quoi s'agit-il en fait c'est une
classe qui regroupe 17 enfants qui ont
éprouvé lors de leur cursus scolaire en
6e et 5e un échec scolaire mais qui ne
sont pas fâchés en total complètement
avec l'école mais qui cependant ben sont
un peu essoufflés par le rythme scolaire
dépassé par le nombre des classes et à
qui on a proposé sur engagement de de
venir dans cette classe à projet
avec comme finalité de réintégrer l'an
prochain euh une troisème classique ou
une troisème prépa pro s'ils ont un
projet professionnel bien précis donc
c'est une année un petit peu
particulière donc en raconte-nous tu as
dû donc t'engager c'est ça signer un un
contrat en fait pour montrer que tu
étais vraiment motivé pour participer à
cette classe pourquoi est-ce que tu l'as
fait toi exactement bah je l'ai fait
parce que déjà le projet théâtre ça ça
me plaisait je j'aime bien le théâtre
parce qu'en fait on n a pas encore parlé
mais c'est vrai que une des originalités
justement de de cette class et que vous
menez tout au long de l'année un projet
théâtre qui va fédérer en fait
l'ensemble des 10 pline autour d'une
œuvre alors qu'est-ce que vous avez
choisi cette année alors nous avons
choisi germina l'an passé c'était les
misérables cette année c'est germinale
tout simplement parce que c'est au
programme des du français en 4e mais
aussi parce que c'est une œuvre qui a
beaucoup de résonance aujourd'hui dans
notre actualité économique et enfin
parce que c'est la c'était la
possibilité pour tous mes collègues de
s'engager dans le travail d'appréhension
et de compréhension du livre auprès des
enfants alors on a tous mis nos
spécialités en œuvre pour vous donner
quelques exemples le la prof de SVT le
professeur de SVT a travaillé sur la
germination parce qu'en fait germinal
aussi c'est tout un symbole hein les
enfants germent tout au long de cette
année on leur redonne confiance et c'est
bah c'est comme dans l'histoire
d'Étienne Lantier où l'éveil la
conscience politique peut permettre
effectivement aussi à des esprits de
germ alors en en musique aussi par
exemple notre professeur a travaillé sur
l'orchestre métallique parce que toutes
ces en art plastique le professeur a
travaillé sur des vidéos en histoire
bien évidemment sur l'âge industriel en
mathématique sur les les statistiques de
remplissage de la salle dans laquelle va
se représenter va être présenter le
spectacle bref beaucoup de tous nos tous
nos tous mes collègues ont travaillé
autour de l'œuvre pour que justement les
enfants l'appréhendent et la sent et la
ressente et et ensuite puisse la jouer
et être guidé par un professeur de
théâtre ça nous y tenions on veut pas de
représentation papier crépon on voulait
vraiment un théâtre vivant associant des
des technologie de vidéo de son de une
modernité c'est pas un spectacle de fin
d'année de dire pas du tout c'est un
vrai projet je dirais presque
professionnel parce que nous sommes tous
des professionnels bien sûr forcément du
spectacleou vous avez fait appel à un
professionnel donc c'est Guillaume
deoura qui est également donc président
de la compagnie l'air de rien versa
exactement et qui a donc ais pris en
charge la classe pendant plusieurs
mois on va regarder un petitte un petit
extrait de d'une interview qu'on a
réalisé avec lui ça fait déjà des mois
qu'il travaillent sur germinal dans
toutes les disciplines ils ont déjà un
bagage après la difficulté c'est la
difficulté de se mettre à nu en fait la
difficulté de de lâcher son comportement
naturel de mais tout ça ça se travaille
avec la confiance avec le groupe et
l'énorme avantage qu'on a eu c'est que
au mois de février on a pu aller à la
mine de valers où là on a pu être avec
des mineurs et filmer plein de plein
d'extraits et là ça a énormément soudé
le groupe c'est dans cette sécurité là
que résultat on peut se développer
s'épanouir et se lâcher en fait quand on
est en théâtre on a plus de possibilité
de de courir de on est plus on est un
peu plus libre mais il faut toujours se
concentrer sur le texte en fait on
n'oublie jamais que l'école ça sert
vraiment à ça on va représenter dans une
semaine alors faut toujours se
concentrer on fait pas les imbéciles
on vient d'entendre Lucas il parle
presque comme un professionnel on fait
pas les imbéciles il ce qu'il tient le
rôle titre Detienne Lantier donc c'est
pas n'importe quoi c'est pression sur
vous nous disiez tout à l'heure juste
avant qu'on écoute donc le metteur en
scène professionnelle que l'idée c'était
aussi qu'il s'approprie qu'il ressente
ce texte qui avait une résonance
particulière dans l'actualité
aujourd'hui est-ce que germinal
justement pour toi est-ce que ça ça te
parle lorsque tu lis ce texte tu en
saisis le le sens complet ça ça t'évoque
quelque choseah en fait germinal pour
moi
c'est c'est c'est pas c'est pas comme
maintenant c'était on on on voit quand
on lit le livre ou même quand on regarde
le film que c'est que c'était dur avant
la vie des des mineurs c'était pas
c'était pas comme la NRE quoi c'était tu
y trouves un écho aussi dans dans ta vie
enfin tu fais des comparaisons avec avec
l'époque bah oui je dis je je je trouve
que nous du coup on a de la chance de
pouvoir être bah
scolarisé voilà qu'on bah vu que là dans
Germinal il y a il y a un esprit aussi
de grève
c'est nous on peut manger tous les jours
à notre fin alors que avant c'était
c'était dur il fallait payer il fallait
il fallait se battre il fallait et sur
l'aspect travail avec un professionnel
comment ça s'est passé pour toi on
entendu ton camarade dire on fait pas
n'importe quoi toi aussi tu fais pas
n'importe quoi bah non c'est sûr c'est
comme a dit Lucas il faut il faut bah il
faut se
concentrer sur sur le texte ils sont
très sérieux oui très très sérieux
pourtant on avait des enfants qui
n'étaient pas nécessairement qui
auraient pu être jugés perdu je rappelle
qu'on a eu trois enfants qui étaient qui
avait qui éprouvait des phobies
scolaires qui venaient d'autres
établissements et qui pendant 6 mois
n'allaiit plus au collège
aujourrouvé pe de venir dans les é
complètement on a même une l'une d'entre
elles qui fait 2 heures de trajet chaque
jour pour venir au collège oui donc
c'est une vraie réussite et satisfaction
pour les enseignantsou pour nous tous
pour tout le monde pour les enfants pour
les enseignants pour le personnel pour
la direction et pour les parents donct
je tiens ce soir à saluer la
participation car dans cette classe nous
avions un papa qui était carrément
caméraman professionnel et qui a donc pu
enregistrer à valers de nombreuses
séquences
ouis une partie vraiment concrète aussi
avec cette visite de de de la mine de de
valersou que qu'est-ce que vous-même les
élèves en ont en ont tiré comme
expérience ben si vous voulez nous on
Avaz été reçu dans un voyage de
reconnaissance et nous on a été très
touché par ces mineurs qui ont arrêté
leur travail en 1989 c'est pas si vieux
que ça et qui regrettaient que les
jeunes ne s'intéressent plus à ce
patrimoine et à leur culture et à leur
histoire or la plus belle réussite qu'on
a eu d'ailleurs le spectacle sera
dédicacé à Alain et Oscar qui sont deux
mineurs donc de valers et qui ont aidé
épauler les enfants tout au long du
tournage à valers et toi ettienne alors
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que le théâtre
t'a donné de plus que tu n'avais pas
avant bah déjà ça m'a le théâtre m'a
aidé à à prendre plus confiance en
moi et et à me dire que rien n'est perdu
quoi
c'est si on peut apprendre un texte de
théâtre on
peut on peut réussir à prendre ses
leçons et du coup euh avoir des bonnes
notes et et pouvoir réussir dans la vie
donc pour toi c'est cette année c'est
une année gagnée bah oui c'est c'est
surtout une année où j'ai pu reprendre
toutes les bases depuis la 6e et c'est
une bonne philosophie rien n'est jamais
perdu ça t'accompagnera dans toute la
vie au quotidien merci à vous deux
Aurélia on va peut-être raeler la date
heement donc la représentation a lieu le
5 avril euh donc il il suffit de
téléphoner pour pour réser
et puis on vous souhaite tout le
meilleur pour la suite merci beaucoup
vous le 7 weekend qui se poursuit avec
Catherine